leader of the lib Dems sir Ed Davey with
me hi um what do the government need to
do to stop these strikes sorting
themselves out well they need to engage
with the unions they say they're doing
that well I think the meeting they had
yesterday was pretty disappointing they
didn't come with the meeting now well a
long last it's taken them months and
that's one of my criticisms is the
government should have acted before
um and we're seeing patients and
passengers disrupted and seeing this
chaos because the government haven't got
a grip of of the issue so yes they need
to talk but they've got to come up with
some some practical way forward and
let's remember the Health Service just
take take that has been in crisis now
for a long time they need reform well it
needs reform it needs more money in we
need to look at Social care one issue
liberal Democrats have been talking
about is the need to help our GPS our
GPS are completely overworked and it's a
real problem getting a GP appointment
for many people across the country we've
well I'm not going to comment on on him
it's he got him he's got to come clear
hasn't he going to be more transparent
but what we do need for our country is
more doctors we need to hire more we
need to recruit more we need to train
more so we want 8 000 more GPS that
would mean people could get the
appointments and what happens when
people can't get a GP appointment is
either they self-medicate well we for
the recent surveys there's a one in six
people when they can't get a GP
appointment are going online
diagnosing and and self-medicating
that's quite risky and one in five are
going to the A E are making the the
issues for our Hospital doctors now
nurses even even more difficult so
that's why liberal Democrats are saying
solve the problem at source make sure
we're giving some real support to our
GPS across the company but people who
can afford it should they be paying to
go privately for GP appointments at the
moment and then those who can't afford
it in other words mean testing GPS now
listen people pay a lot in tax
there's a lot of people out there a lot
of your viewers who pay is huge amount
of tax it's not unreasonable for them to
ask the government to provide quality
services and you know the short term
well in the in the short term the
government have got to step up I mean we
I've given you the ideas that the
Democrats have for GPS well there's some
things you could do quickly let me give
you an example
um we've been arguing that paramedics
that nurse practitioners that
pharmacists should have more ability to
write prescriptions go on a training
course many of them actually do but they
could do more of that that would take
some of the workload off GPS and
bureaucracy and that would free up more
time so things that we could do now and
I I really despair this government let
me give you another example uh which
people talk about a lot and that's care
and I think you and I have talked about
carers and social care before
um a lot of people are in hospital
unnecessarily and now the government
made this announcement yesterday as if
they just discovered it they're going to
put some money in the front line and we
don't know when it's actually going to
arrive but they need a national plan a
proper plan to make sure that people can
be discharged more quickly either to
occur him or frankly to the home where
they're giving far more more support to
the family and to the friends who can
can who want to take part it's a good
idea that the government's putting
forward well um it's good that they've
noticed that there's a problem here a
long last Democrats have been talking
about it for a long time I don't think
it's a proper plan I think it's I think
uh it's a minute step forward I welcome
it but I've got to do far more far more
okay if we're going to tackle that and
make sure that people can be discharged
to free up the bed so we the ambulance
can can uh unload and the patients can
get the care they need without having to
wait for hours so you know whether it's
making sure people can get those GP
appointments whether it's making sure
patients are discharged these are common
sense solutions that liberal Democrats
and others have been talking about for
years and the government have just not
listened and so this crisis they try to
blame it on Covert don't they and that
really annoys me because coven may have
made it a bit worse and let's not yeah
but but a lot of these problems were
before covert and give you a classic
example in 2016. in 2016
um George Osborne the formatory
chancellor in 2016 he got rid of
bursters for student nurses he did and
so fewer was it the um present
Chancellor no I think it was George I
was born to be fair and what happened
was fewer people went into nursing to
say nursing so the shortage of nurses so
a conservative policy back in 2016 made
undermined our Health Service ahead of
covid and it takes a while as you were
saying before to train people so a lot
of these problems can be laid fair and
squarely at the door of conservative
governments since 2015 and I think
people are now seeing that and I think
people really want to make sure that
their families their communities are
properly looked after and they really
feel this Government is out of touch
um can I talk to you about Westminster
accounts yeah sure
yeah sure um let's have a look at yours
should we since 2019 you've declared 441
000 pounds 600 extra income gifts and
donations all uh completely above board
of course the three largest sources of
money include 121 700 from Herbert Smith
free Hills
57 980 from next energy capital and 30
790 from Christopher Leach those are the
three biggest
um
first of all how do you feel about that
being highlighted in the way that it is
at the moment with this tool I actually
welcome it and I actually want to praise
the sky and tortoise for doing this work
it's really important we have greater
transparency and also because it's quite
a complicated set of issues that we have
a proper debate about it so I I
completely uh welcome that and I'm happy
to go through any of your questions
about those numbers because as you said
in uh quite rightly they've all been
properly declared and they've all been
totally above board
but previously you were forced to resign
from your two consultancy jobs no it
wasn't no sorry tell me I voluntarily
reside okay I was absolutely not forced
to resign let's say you step down from
your two consultancy jobs uh now you see
that many other MPS
um have got secondary employment which
is very lucrative do you think that it
was the right decision that you made to
step down at the time yeah I mean let me
tell you a little bit about those
consultancies the figures you had for uh
earthmus free Hills International
Capital they were consultancies that I
was doing to earn some money uh in order
to help support my son John who's
severely disabled who needs 24 7 care
so that it incurs extra costs now and
I'm an old dad and I think about what's
going to happen when I'm dead who's
going to look after him so I was making
some provision yeah and um I'm lucky
enough to be able to do that I know
there are you know hundreds of thousands
of families with disabled children
disabled relatives who who aren't lucky
enough to make provision and one of the
things I'm doing in Parliament is
campaigning for them for carers for
disabled people so they get a better
deal because I know how expensive it is
and that's why I why do those jobs now
why did I uh voluntarily step down from
those was we had that Scandal if you
remember before uh December last year
November December last year
over the conservative MP for Minister
Owen Patterson
who not only not only did he have a lot
of consultancies but he he broke the
rules in a very very severe way and cons
there was a big debate as you remember
at the time
um conservative MPS voted to protect him
and then they had to reneg on that
protection of Their Own
because uh quite rightly it was a public
reaction to that rule breaking by
conservative by conservative MP and I
decided that I wanted to show some
leadership on the issue of consultances
and second jobs and I decided although
it was you know I'm still thinking about
my son of course I decided to resign
from those and I was therefore able to
to make sure I could make the argument
for greater transparency and for title
rules on jobs and donations which is
what liberal Democrats have argued I
mean we we have led the debate in
Parliament to get big money out of
politics we've argued for years now okay
that we need to clean the clean this up
greater transparency and we even had
talks with the conservative labor party
a few years ago and they walked away
from some proposals to deal with his
problem and I I one reason I really
welcome what you're doing with toy toys
is I want to have that debate again I
want to clean up British politics I want
this transparency I want title rules and
I want to Reform Party
yeah so I suppose the the my question
remains do you support MPS who have
second jobs or given what's happened to
you and given some of the illustrations
that we've made with this new tool do
you think
the rules should be clearer or you
shouldn't have a second job if you're an
MP well I think there should absolutely
be stricter rules and we need all the
parties to get around the table to make
sure they are clear well first of all we
should make sure that consultancies in
no way have any conflicts of interest at
all I think that's what people really
really worry about and there is a case
which I'm really happy to engage with
about getting rid of all uh second jobs
um but I'm I also conscious that there
are ones that help MPS do their jobs or
there may be specific examples in their
life so I gave you the example of my son
John who
um who certainly disabled needs that 24
7 care and as a father I wanted to make
sure I was making some provision for him
so there are examples like that that
would have to be part of engagements
where you get paid 300 000 pounds for an
hour or whatever well I don't know maybe
it's Boris Johnson who has that one I
certainly have seen that but you think
that that it's reasonable within the
remit of being an MP
well
um I would suggest that MPS would need
to seriously look at themselves for
being paid 300 000 pounds for an hour's
speech engagement and then the rules
need to be tightened up on that fine
absolutely that's really why I welcome
this debate okay because I think we have
to have exactly that that discussion
what about people like Theresa May who
was the Prime Minister and when she was
the Prime Minister she stopped some of
her Representatives going to the Middle
East because of what have happened to
Jamal khashoggi and then recently went
to Saudi Arabia and got paid more than a
hundred thousand pounds well um I don't
know the pacifics of that case so um
yeah but but I think it's fair to any
politicians I mean Theresa May or anyone
else from any political party liberal
Democrat labor preservative that they
come on your program and one thing I
welcome about this initiative you've
taken you would have accepted that looks
duplicitous on the face of it well I
think questions are rightly being asked
about that but I don't know what her
answers are so neither do I I have asked
Jess to come on the show well I hope she
does here we are I hope she and any
other a politician from your analysis
which raises questions I think they
should come and be transparent and
answer for them in the way that that
I've done and I know other colleagues
have done from all political parties
um and then then the public your viewing
public can can decide whether or not uh
people in the right thing in politics is
complicated you know to to stand for the
leadership of the liberal democrats for
example uh I had to raise quite a lot of
money it was during covid and about a
third of those donations are actually
related to my bid to be leader of the
party uh and but you do acknowledge that
the rules do need to be changed yeah no
100 I mean liberal Democrats have argued
that for a long long time and that's why
we welcome this all I was saying from my
own society and I would say it for
colleagues who've been leaders of other
parties leadership candidates in other
parts internal elections when you're in
that category you've often have to raise
money for those internal elections to
see if you could become the leader of
your party and uh it's important so you
were successful with that well yeah
second time around well there we go hey
um just a very quick thought before I
let you go
um you were obviously a very
compassionate man um what is your
overriding emotion for Harry at the
moment
well you know I don't really want to
comment on the roof the royal family
issues I think politicians
I'm coming to that what I think and I
don't know about you I've see friends
and families where there's there are
disputes
and those those natural disputes in
families that occur you know on almost
every family can can create a lot of
hurt a lot of hurt quite deep hurt
and so you know my overriding motion for
Harry for any member of the raw family
is you know I personally want to leave
them alone and not comment on me I don't
want to make the hurt of other human
beings uh worse and um you know I'll
just leave it leave it there because I
know other probably every person
watching this program can relate to the
hurt of family disputes and sadness okay
Mr Ed it's great to see you thanks very
much indeed for coming thank you
appreciate it